do you like birds birds yeah I'm going
to birds I really like pigeons it's not
like a girl stop it
hi uh what's your name uh my name is
Shea I'm Marielle nice to meet you nice
to meet you too what are your red flags
communism
the button just talks just tell me what
to do red flag for Marielle is if
someone has a dog you don't like dogs I
like dogs am I racist
a reason because I think she said male
that doesn't like dogs and I'm like
marielle's a weird name for a black girl
[Music]
Jesus Christ is it because of the dog I
just don't like picking up their poop
I'm Sequoia
hey I'm Marielle nice to meet you I
really love your shirt those colors they
really pop
Marielle loves dogs
do you
I am okay about dogs okay okay I have a
dog okay yeah this is crazy the way they
set this up they set her up first stop
okay she looked like she wrote in here
on a broomstick Mario look like a witch
who owns 30 cats I'm not surprised she
don't like dogs she looked like she
prefers getting them now as for setting
her up with two people who got dogs
that's cruel it seems like everyone
insane I'm sorry that's okay my dog's
like a pretty big part of my life so no
that's okay I would have been the same
if you didn't like my cat I'm glad you
get it
witches they got cats she got kids ain't
that what I told y'all ain't she look
like somebody who wrote in here yeah
yeah
Hi Chelsea reads people's poems let me
see your dominant hand
you're very caring you give more to
others than you give to yourself you
have great circulation do you not smoke
only when I'm really drunk
I just think it's crazy that she's
reading her Palm
but just can't read the fact that she
about to get busted out yeah she can't
read the buttons so much for a fortune
teller yeah
you see that ABBA did y'all listen if
anybody hires this weirdo to do anything
in the future you already know you
deserve this help because you decide for
yourself she was reading her whole Palm
in her future in her past but couldn't
see that coming you gotta go I'm Sequoia
I'm Rosie nice to meet you Rosie is
terrified of birds oh like all birds
yeah so like no outside eating you can't
do like a picnic what if a seagull
swoops down has it happened to you it
has okay so like here's the thing with
Birds because you was eating some [ __ ]
that is delicious my girl yeah I know
you so fully [ __ ] yes my girl they are
dinosaurs certainly scared of dinosaurs
factual are you not
whoa whoa whoa whoa I felt The Vibes
like you wanted to eat outside and I
don't want to love you to get outside
okay cool that's nice to meet you nice
to meet you listen watch the two
lesbians talking about eating out eating
out eating out after a while it's like
[ __ ] eat each other's [ __ ] like
one of her doesn't want to eat out I
want to eat outside I wanna eat outside
let's eat outside eat out eat out eat it
eat out eat out eat each other out you
know what's just eat it those funny
thing is just eat it funny thing is like
she's like
you know why she don't want to eat out
because of birds
right off the bat I love your outfit oh
thank you so much I love yours too do
you like birds birds yeah I'm into Birds
I really like pigeons is that like a
girl stop it
that was weird
I'm not allowed pigeons of all birds
I think that they're cute
goodbye
are you doing a connection
um I definitely feel it's giving more
like friendship so okay so it's more
friendship Vibes more so yeah okay yeah
yeah well then
all right
all right girl
why don't you think she pressed uh I
think she didn't want to hurt my
feelings
and I'm cool with that too
[Music]
that's your name I'm Teresa what's your
name Rosie Teresa was last time you saw
someone naked I think it was it was two
days ago
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right
there was a lot of judgment in that
do you [ __ ] on the first date and the
[ __ ] is like every time but
okay yeah oh
you do it how you doing yeah
she's terrified of the light bro
so this young lady is a very special
person in my life she's around my place
maybe three to four times a week we get
up to a lot of Mischief playing around
all kinds of goofy things at first she
was terrified you could see uh she was
scared of the light she didn't
understand what was going on but she got
to know it a little bit and get used to
it
oh
why did you do that say who's who's
cheesy what do you think
there you go she's realizing it's fine
the Galaxy projector will light up your
room and make you think that you're in
outer space with countless stars that
nebulae surrounding you you want me to
close the light
of course so we close this boom
CeCe come take your power
when I'm working when I'm home I spend
so much time editing it's nice to be
able to just switch up the lights and
feel completely different just based off
of one click of the button even using
the well integrated app where you can
change the lights based off whatever
mood you're going through so whether
you're getting romantic whether you're
having fun whether you just want to get
pensive and start thinking a little bit
differently the Galaxy projector is a
great way for you to change your room
without having to change it too much you
feel me so for those who are looking for
the perfect gift for others or
themselves this is your chance go to the
link in the description below use the
discount code Abba preach and get 20 off
so take advantage don't waste any time
click the link in the description below
who was it the friend oh Saucy we were
we went to the sauna together so oh that
was such a like good answer I thought
you were gonna be like you know we sure
felt worried about that no actually I
wouldn't know well they slept with each
other in the sauna
no we did not I'm about to say oh crazy
such an instigator
really did you sleep with them no not in
the no we didn't have you slept with
them
possibly yes do you sleep with a lot of
your friends I do not okay no I think
there's a line between friendship and
whatnot but I'm starting to realize
there's Dimensions to I'm not gonna lie
man after I bust the nut and I'm laying
down beside
I kind of like it when she's like
I've been visited by aliens before like
that [ __ ] kind of fire I'm not gonna lie
because my head's already in space so
let's talk about us I'm like hey man you
in my head's face right now
because I was not in the room with you
but now I'm back what's going on UFOs
let's go talk to me what's going on
speaking of unidentified objects you
trying to catch some more because I'm
not done shooting I'm serious I really
do like it what's up yeah when you talk
about stars and like astrology that [ __ ]
bores the [ __ ] out of yeah but what's he
like yo let's talk about eggs so that's
my [ __ ] shout outs to her
don't say [ __ ] like that say like what
you're gonna have a barrage of we're
[ __ ] in your DMs oh yeah if you're
with the UFOs holler at me and if you
got a list we [ __ ] yeah cause you
sound wet
looking forward to hearing from you I
don't know that's what I'm coming up on
being 23 years old in this world 23.
yeah how old are you if I may ask
I'm 34. is that a is that a problem
no if you're trying to be my sugar mama
baby
no no
sorry hey you my kind of girl she she's
not like yo listen let's do it for the
memes she said he's trying to be my
sugar mama yes girl
yes
yes
this is a sickness but I enjoyed it
because I don't like so do me but I do
like scissors eh I like it when they
touch like this because it is tulips a
pair kissing like this it is a intimacy
it's beautiful the other way around it
is in this rupturing we don't like this
one
I like financially independent people
okay and I'm not nobody sugar mama if
anything I have a sugar daddy and he
knows who like who he is
I love that for you but you mad cute
though if you haven't said that
we would have still been rolling hey how
you doing hey I'm Charlie I'm Rosie nice
to meet you Rose nice to meet you you
have a nice calm cool hands my hands
yeah they're like cool like I'm I'm
nervous as hell thank you I'm bisexual
so how do you feel about that dude I'm
open Love Is Love okay yeah
all right I'm sorry love is love but you
can love that [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna
lightly be Percy but I don't mind like
because I'm open but I'm not that open
you know what I'm saying like I'm not
like
this [ __ ] I'm over here
you know what I what it is I I can't
stand it when people do this whole
empathy empathy thing but the reasons
behind what all I do are super shallow
and like whatever you know what I mean
like it's just
a fan of it I'm just yeah I'm not
feeling you see
that nigga's a Munch
what was the reason what was the reason
no I think physically okay
uh I'm just looking for something
different cool but you're beautiful
she's not saying what she's saying but
we all understood what she was trying to
say so why don't we just say it clearly
because it hurt but we all know the big
girl knows because she was very
perceptive even earlier when the girl
said she didn't want to hurt my feelings
when she didn't press the
buttons so we all know it's fine
but the more you feel the need to beat
around the bush the more I feel the need
to just call it around but they're
lesbians they beat around I've spent too
much time in the bushes there's not
enough space get the [ __ ] out so what
I'm trying to say is just say it
for those who know and watch the channel
they know how you doing okay how are you
I'm good I'm trying to have a nice to
meet you nice to meet you Anna so how
are you I'm 23 23 23.
that's what I hear I mean she wasn't
down for the last big girl she won't be
done for this one she's not the same
kind of big I knew it was gonna happen
how old are you can you guess you're 26.
sorry a little bit too young for me
thank you yeah no problem it was nice
meeting you how you doing how's your
night I'm Tunisia I like your outfit
you're very pretty
thank you yeah of course how old do you
think this girl is
exactly
oh I see what you did exactly how do you
think that this girl is not it's not the
same age yeah she's very beautiful yeah
I find you very attractive thank you
thank you I guess my my only question is
uh how old are you
five 25 okay okay this is a little bit
younger than I'm I'm I'm by Dave I love
older women can you guess how old I am
32 36 36 yeah is that too old for you
that's not too old for me at all I love
your age thank you thank you I mean 25
we can work with it she's
closer
you're closer to 49 she is to 22.
you're 40.
it's not because I've been saying that
I've been 40 for the past five years and
you know I've been saying that I've been
saying that every time I've been talked
for the past five years now I'm pushing
40. I was 35. and it's only this year
I'm like I'm 40. no last year I would
say I was 42. I'm basically four I'm now
I'm 40. I've been saying that and my
girl
you are closer you are 40. shout out to
you and closer to 40 then she's closer
to whatever age your proper age is or
whatever what not
so what Abba said
it's cool like I actually like this
episode because they all took the
rejection super well done episodes and I
wasn't nearly as awkward so you know
that was interesting to watch lesbians
go through it but I will say and I mean
at the end the home goes front a little
bit about why she was saying no but it's
okay it's fine a lot of us do that a lot
of us do that we all do and I put myself
in there because I probably might have
done that with a girl two and a pair
absolutely so I'm not even gonna hold
you but we know what it is and it's only
my job on this channel to tell y'all
what it is